the u.s dollar just hit a 20-year high
now that might be confusing because
inflation's raging in america and anyone
holding dollars they're suffering right
well both things can be true here's
exactly how this works so if we go ahead
and we look at the u.s dollar we think
of price in comparison to its peers and
on that metric alone the us dollar is
hitting that 20-year high you can see
here in this article what they're
talking about is that the us dollar
index which actually measures the dollar
against six of their peers has surged to
that 20-year high now that's going all
the way back to 2002 we haven't seen
these levels but at the same exact time
that the dollar is strengthening against
its peers we are seeing 8.6 inflation of
the united states a 40-year high so you
have high inflation but if you had to
pick a fiat currency the dollar's been
the best place to be compared to other
fiat currencies and so naturally
investors have to say to themselves if
i'm gonna have fiat exposure i want
dollars the dollar is still the king but
if you actually want to be able to
survive over a long period of time
holding any fiat currency ends up being
a losing strategy and that's where you
see many investors rushing to hard
assets things like real estate or things
like digital sound money and bitcoin or
even in some cases stocks as well now of
course in the short term over the last
six to eight months we've seen many
asset prices crashing the fed has been
raising interest rates they're now
conducting quantitative tightening the
fed is intentionally crashing asset
prices but that doesn't mean that you
necessarily should run away from them in
fact if the assets are still performing
just as well as they were 8 12 15 18
months ago and the price is lower it
just means that they're on sale now you
have to go evaluate each individual
asset for yourself you have to think to
yourself what is my time horizon how
long do i want to hold this asset is it
actually performing as well or better
than it was in the past and the price is
just down or has there been some
fundamental difference in the actual
asset itself now of course while all
this is going on inflation is raging the
us dollar is strengthening against other
fiat pairs and i think what we're going
to see is that the u.s dollar will
remain king among fiat currencies but at
the same exact time other assets are
going to go up and up and up over a long
period of time 10 20 30 years because in
the united states and around the world
central banks have to devalue their
currencies in order to go ahead and
actually service their debt the end of
the day the global macro environment
super complex there's a lot of moving
parts if you think that you've mastered
it you're probably wrong keep your head
on a swivel make sure you keep educating
yourself understand as much of the
nuance as possible and then just get a
really long time horizon because over a
long enough time horizon it's much
easier to be right than in these
intra-day intro week and intro month
moves
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time